quantum entanglement summer squares and
longer and conjectures prohibition
thanks facade for inviting me and thank
you all for staying for the absolutely
last talk the grand finale of this
awesome workshop so yeah so I'm gonna
tell you about quantum entanglement sum
of squares and the log rank conjecture
joint work with both Barack and
destroyed on so yeah I guess a couple
days ago you saw like some technique to
prove lower bounds for sum of squares
little pseudo calibration then this
morning's lil and David told you how to
design average-case
algorithms for average case problems
using some squares and this talk is
gonna be about worst-case algorithm
design using you know the same technique
so in particular this is going to be
about a problem that for now I'm going
to call the find a rank one matrix in a
subspace problem and that's gonna be a
mouthful but I'm gonna stick to it
because the quantum the coin like this
problem comes from some quantum
information motivation will tell you
that motivation in a bit but I won't
carry around that name for the purpose
of the talk so the talk is going to be
completely classical great so in this
problem you're given a basis that spans
a linear subspace of n by n matrices
okay and you're promised that there is a
rank one matrix which is completely
contained inside the subspace so this
rank one matrix is described by two unit
vectors U and V and UV transpose there
is some UV transpose that you're
promised cut lives in this subspace W
which is given as input to you your goal
is to find some rank one matrix
described by some unit vectors x and y
so that XY transposed is in this
subspace W ok so here is my lame attempt
to make a drawing for this problem so in
some sense this is a question of finding
a point in the intersection of two sets
both the sets are actually extremely
nice and well studied one of the sets is
just a linear subspace which is actually
input to the problem the other set is
this manifold of rank one matrices
it's an algebraic variety in a sense
it's basically it's just a solution to a
system of quadratic equations the issue
of course is that we know how to find
points in the decesion of two convex
sets by a standard convex optimization
machinery
one of these sets here is you know while
it's nice it's not really convex so you
know we for example cannot apply a
standard content optimization machinery
to find a point in the intersection here
okay great so just to just to tell you
why it's a it's a problem of this this
problem itself can be thought of as just
a problem of finding a solution to a
system of quadratic equations here is
sort of a simple formulation to convince
you of that if B 1 B 2 B R is a given
basis to me for that spans the subspace
W then you know I'm looking for some
linear combination which is described by
coefficient C 1 C 2 up to C smaller so
there's some CIB I equals XY transposed
XY are also my variables here so in
particular this is a quadratic equation
in X Y and C's and you know to force
nonzero solutions I can I can add some
constraint that says that you know the
l2 square norm of x and y has to be
let's say 1 okay so you all agree that
this is a problem of finding system you
know solution to a system of quadratic
equations and this is going to be you
know this is going to be what bother
says for the last 20 minutes or so so
just to tell you that I'm not super
concerned about finding a point in the
exact intersection I will be happy if
you give me you know some rank one
matrix which is close to the subspace
but that leads into a question of what
is the right notion of distance in this
context so really in some sense I could
have thought of this question as finding
some vector in an N square dimensional
Euclidean space I'm just thinking of
them as n by n matrices because the
structure on the vector I'm looking at
is the rank oneness and it is sort of
easily understood in terms of matrices
ok but that also such as the right
question of distance the distance notion
would be the Euclidean distance of a
vector from a subspace in the in the
space of matrices you know it goes by
the name of Frobenius norm so what you
want is that XY transpose when projected
to you know this subspace W linearly
projected should basically be you know I
should get almost all of the Frobenius
mom back so up to let's say some 1%
error okay so I'm in fact so that's the
notion of distance and moving forward
I'm going to make basically fix this
epsilon to be you know point 0 1 just 1%
so that I don't have to carry around
extra parameter one other simplification
I'm going to do moving forward is that
instead of looking for you know rank one
matrices with like 2
so like a symmetric rank one matrices
I'm a look at symmetric rank one
matrices this makes no difference to the
algorithm analysis or the result but you
know just like one less vector for me to
worry about so are there any questions
about the problem the problem definition
is clear okay great so so I want to tell
you about a little bit about where this
forum comes from there's obviously a
direct motivation from quantum
information but I also want to remind
you that if you don't care about the
quantum information part that much this
is an example of what I like to call a
structured eigenvalue problem and you've
seen several examples of this hopefully
you know in in in other forms basically
this is a question of fine so you're
given some subspace and you are
interested in finding you know vector in
a subspace that satisfies some
additional structural property so for
example the structure could be bullion
ax t and this corresponds to max code or
this searcher could be like sparsity and
it corresponds to small cell expansion
if you care about machine learning then
you know there is some other like sparse
B's here like program that fall into
this regime so you know the problem that
we're interested in today is sort of you
know the structure itself is this rank
one this when when the when the vector
is looked at as a n by n matrix and
you're you're interested in you know
finding such a vector in the subspace so
it's an example of a structure I can
value problem this particular problem
goes by the name of best separable say
this is the name I was avoiding in
quantum information and and and the
subspace actually comes from top eigen
space of a certain matrix called as a
measurable matrix again not important
for this for this talk but the reason we
care about this algorithmic problem is
that well I mean it's this algorithm
problem stands at sort of this position
which we want to understand this
difference between entangled quantum
states and you know separable quantum
states so in some sense it's this
problem is sort of like one angle to
studying separable ax T versus
entanglement and again not important if
you don't know what that is very
concretely there is a quantum complexity
conjecture which relates to
characterizing the power of to prove our
quantum proofs and if this algorithm has
a fast enough algorithm like a quasi
polynomial time algorithm then it turns
out that somewhat surprising complexity
class collapse happens and that's one
reason to sort of care about this
problem if you design a fast enough
algorithm
something nice or depending on where you
are something bad happens but again not
not super important for us we you know
hopefully you like the problem by itself
and you are interested in designing a
fast algorithm for it regardless perhaps
but I I don't know if it's a useable
structure so I there the W comes from
top eigenspace of you know measurement
operators on bipartite quantum systems
perhaps that's not the most general
subspace have to think about it but I'm
not sure there is yeah I can't think of
any usable structural information that
I'm losing in this formulation so that
that sort of yeah so this is the view
okay so you can think of states okay if
there are pure states you can think of
them as density matrices or vectors and
in this word I'm adopting the vector
view in some sense really what you are
supposed to think of these as you know
like this corresponds to the density
matrix which is like so if it was you
you V transpose it corresponds the
density matrix u u transpose tensor
product VB transposed so one thing is
that this in this form right right so
you basically stands for the pure state
for the density matrix u u transposed
does that make sense yeah so I'm
sticking to the symmetric version now
yes in general it would be an asymmetric
version for the algorithmic purpose I'm
going to stick to the symmetric version
now okay you can forget about the
quantum application for now and we can
take it offline okay good so so what do
we know about this problem so quantum
folks have figured out lots of cool
stuff about this question in particular
we know that if you make this epsilon
thingy here very very tiny like
something that goes to zero over the
dimension then it's going to be np-hard
in fact even if I make this like a fixed
constant like point zero one that we
care about today it turns out that there
is a quasi polynomial lower bound if you
assume that 3sat cannot be solved into
religion of n time okay and and in
special cases and so when this subspaces
W are some somewhat special subspaces
that arise from you know top eigenspace
of some special measurement matrices
then there is in fact a quasi polynomial
upper bound for this problem but the
bottom line is that there is no non
trivial algorithm by non trivial I mean
something that you know does not do
brute-force search over all possible
vectors over the unit sphere which runs
in the I to the over N time there is no
notable algorithm for this problem for
general subspaces okay that brings me to
the main result the main result is like
a slightly non-trivial algorithm for
this problem this is going to be a 2 to
the root n time algorithm up to Polydor
factors for you know this find a rank
one matrix in a subspace problem and
this is gonna be based on rounding you
know some sum of squares relaxation for
this problem ok and in there are some
quantum core always that we can safely
ignore great are there any questions ok
so now I'm gonna tell you about the
algorithm and before telling you about
algorithm I'm going to pontificate about
the general approach of algorithm design
using convex relaxations so bear with me
so here is how we are taught how to
design algorithms we say well we start
with some intractable formulation no
quadratic equations or integer programs
or whatever and then you know you you
choose a convex relaxation for this
problem so you know if this red point
sort of denote let's say the set of all
X's that satisfy the system of quadratic
equations that we care about in the
present context then in some sense the
tightest possible convex is accessioned
you would want to choose as the convex
hull of this points but usually you
don't know about this point in some
sense that's the whole problem that you
don't know this convex set so you choose
some relaxation that would you know
definitely include this convex hull okay
then you know you use some generic
technology to find a point inside this
convex set let's say using a lip sight
and then you know you have to do this
task of rounding which is take a point
inside this larger extended convex set
the relaxation and you know map it to
something that is close to a real
solution right and I want to remind you
that the set of rank one matrices is not
convex which means that it's not enough
to project this point over this pollito
you really want to get close to one of
the vertices okay so that's the rounding
problem but of course there was a twist
even though this is so that the point I
want to make is that even though the
algorithms papers are written in this
your way in which you know the
relaxation happens and then the rounding
happens I want to say that actually in
many cases the rounding informs a
relaxation and the relaxation sort of
drives around and it's not really a
one-sided affair here and the point
being that you know you you have some
basic laceration and you start rounding
it and in the analysis you discovered
that foul it would have been nice if I
had this inequality you know that my
solution satisfied so you go in
satisfied you know add that inequality
like hyperplane to your collection
ization make it like stronger and you
continue analysis maybe you do this back
and forth a couple of times and
eventually you end up with a relaxation
that is sort of tied down to your
rounding that helps your rounding right
so in other words I want to say that you
know it's not strictly speaking correct
that you know the relaxation happens
before the rounding in many cases the
rounding sort of informs the relaxation
we actually choose okay and you know you
collect years of injustice in presenting
algorithms papers what I'm going to do
is you know present the rounding first
and you know give you the relaxation
later or perhaps never so okay so so
that was you know our quadratic equation
system that we were interested in
solving so in this in this approach we
don't care about choosing the right
convex relaxation we just choose the
tightest possible convex relaxation ever
which is the convex hull of the you know
actual solutions and of course I don't
know they said that's the whole problem
but I'm going to ignore that issue for
now
okay I'm going to imagine that there is
an Oracle that finds a point inside this
set okay so you know somebody gives me
this point inside and I worry about the
problem of rounding which is given a
point inside this convex hull how do I
add something close to a vertex of this
you know polytope okay I'm going to call
this a rounding problem okay and now
what you do is you know you come up with
some Domenic procedure hopefully it's
nice simple you go and like dive in to
find what do you require in the analysis
of the sounding procedure this is
similar to what still was saying you
know in the context of density
composition you want to find out the
constraints that were really important
the hyper planes that were sort of
satisfied by actual solutions you want
to find out which one of them's were
really important in your analysis and
then hopefully they're not too many of
them not not hopefully not all of them
are really required so you go and add
only those hyper planes or only those
constraints that were useful in your
analysis hopefully this will be a small
set and you would end up with like a
small convex relaxation and in
and since you're rounding only use the
fact that you know you you you that's
you the rounding sort of use only the
subset of the hyperplanes that were
satisfied by the actual set in some
sense you actually managed to show that
even if you find a point inside here
the transformation that you do in the
rounding would end up mapping it close
to a vertex of this pollito so in some
sense you didn't really use that you're
inside this convex hull that's what your
argument already showed okay so this is
all vague and I'm going to make it
concrete in a second but hopefully this
abstract you know mumbo-jumbo make sense
sense great so now we're going to trying
to implement this approach for you know
our problem so we first want to start
with the tightest possible convex
relaxation so that I said is the convex
all of the actual solutions I'm going to
think of them as distributions over you
know X's that satisfy the system of
quadratic equations here okay so that's
great
so now I have a distribution you know
over X's that satisfy the system of
quadratic equations later on I do want
to make an algorithm out of this so you
know looking ahead I realize that if I
come up with a rounding algorithm whose
input itself takes like a huge space to
represent then I'm in sort of deep
trouble in trying to make that whole
step algorithmic later on okay and here
that here I face that issue because you
know this mu could take exponentially
more parameters to describe it's a
distribution over the units field so you
know for all I know it could be
supported on exponentially many vectors
so what I want to do is somehow like
reduce the number of parameters in order
to sort of you know have some chance of
making this whole thing algorithmic
later on so here I'm gonna do the first
lossy step I'm going to make an answer
to that I'm going to look at only degree
up to D moments of this distribution mu
okay this is an artificial tactic I'm
going to play just so that the number of
parameters of the distribution requires
to be specified hard you know n to the
ofd now so if B is like non-trivial is
smaller than n then at least I have a
small object that I'm thinking about
okay so my problem that becomes given
degree D moments of a distribution mu
supported over X's that satisfy the
system of quadratic equations how do I
map it to a point close to you know and
one of the actual solutions okay great
so that brings me to the main step of
the proof the the rounding algorithm and
and this in some sense is sort of the
conceptual heart of you know the proof
in some sense that the next steps it's
not like they're there they need to be
done etc but you know they're they're
basically they're technical things that
you need to do at the end to have an
algorithm but in some sense all the
conceptual ideas happen in this step to
where you want to somehow round just an
actual distribution from low degree
moments okay great so just to remind you
here is our problem I have a
distribution in fact low degree moments
of a distribution which is supported on
actual XS that satisfy the system of
quadratic equations I thought I was not
saying anything controversial okay so a
rounding problem is that I have degree
up to D moments of this distribution you
know or supported over X's that satisfy
the quadratic equations and I want to
get to like some single X star or unit
vector such that the rank one matrix
defined by it you know it's close to
being in the subspace W great so here
I'm going to do let's see how it goes so
let's try to do this proof say mu is
uniform over some set of vectors u 1 u 2
up to u capital n okay now without loss
of generality I'm always going to think
of distributions as uniform over some
set and you know like this this sort of
is sort of without was original
generality but if even if you don't you
know don't see it just imagine that
these are all the distributions are care
about for some reason right now okay
now this n by the way it could be really
huge as we talked the distributions
could be supported over you know some
some live like a full epsilon that of
the unit sphere and then it could be
like exponentially large okay but all we
know is that you know for every UI in
this list UI UI transpose lives in the
subspace W okay so and since I'm only
going to think of this uniform
distribution I'm going to think of
distributions and says interchangeably
from what happens in what happens
further now okay
great so now you know if I had one wish
to ask you know the genie I would ask
like for the set of rank four matrices
to be convex okay and I want to convince
you that if the genie
rented this wish to me then I'm really
done okay so here is the simple argument
say the set of rank one matrices was
convex it's not okay but so say for the
purpose of this argument it happened to
be convex you know in the in some part
of universe then you know if I take the
expectation of UI UI transpose with
respect to the distribution mu which is
basically uniform so it's just 1 over N
times sum of UI UI transpose then you
know this is a linear combination of
this rank four matrices UI UI transpose
so in particular it lives in the
subspace W linearity right and this is
also a convex combination if the set of
rank one matrices were convex then this
would be itself a rank four matrix so
that's awesome I have a rank one matrix
in a subspace W so I round and be done
okay one one thing to notice also is
that you know this expectation has
entries which has just degree two
moments of the distribution mu so I
don't even need the whole distribution
mu for this algorithm to work I just
need the first two moments right okay so
we we are in a great awesome world if
rank one matrices were convex but you
know even even the GE you know tells you
that you should not ask for something
stupid so this this obviously is not a
greatest idea in the world so but we're
going good so we want to somehow relax
this notion of convexity that was useful
to us and still make this you know may
get some non stupid version of this idea
to work okay so this may offend some of
the people and if this notion of
approximate convexity bothers you this
never appears in the paper so feel free
to read the paper ignore to talk okay
this this this notion exist only in the
talk but hopefully it will make sense to
you so this approximation of convexity
is designed just so that my rounding you
know argument that I was telling you in
the previous slide you know can work in
some sense okay so I would say that the
set of rank four matrices is Delta
convex okay if for every subset of unit
vectors you know every subset of unit
vectors defining some rank four matrices
let's say u 1 u 2 up to u capital n
there is a subset s which is Delta of
measure at least Delta inside this
subset that I'm looking at
and the expectation with respect to you
know uniform distribution on this set s
of UI UI transpose is close to Rank 1
okay so previously just to remind you
you know that assuming that the set of
Rank 1 matrix is convex is like assuming
that the set of rank one matrices is one
convex like if I take any subset the
expectation of UI UI transpose on that
subset would be rank 1 now I'm trying
trying to ask for a relaxed version of
it all I want is that for every possible
subset of rank one matrices there should
be a delta subset of it such that the
expectation of UI UI transpose
restricted to it should be close to Rank
1 if this happens for some Delta I would
say that rank one matrices is our Delta
convex is the definition clear great so
just to remind you what close to Rank 1
means it just means that if I look at
this matrix take the top eigenvector
then you know this eigen the eigenvalue
associated with this eigenvector
dominates in for being is not okay so
now I want to convince you that I can do
this
you know wishful thinking argument with
Delta convexity okay and it's it's
really trivial you know say mu is
uniform again over this some subset of
you know unit vectors such that you know
there were there were solutions to to
the program I care about and same you
happen to be sorry suppose the set of
Rank 1 matrix was Delta convex then what
I will do is you know say I could also
find this set you know which witness as
Delta convexity efficiently while I'm
fishing I might wish for everything then
what I do is you know just compute the
expectation of UI UI transpose restrict
it to this set take the top eigenvector
and round and just by almost
construction and we have ensured that
this will succeed okay now one thing we
need to worry about is in the previous
argument when we had one convexity the
final expectation the entries of this
matrix that we actually constructed were
degree two moments of the distribution
now we're to worry about whether you
know this thing that I get out of this
rounding procedure can be written in
terms of low degree moments of you know
this distribution mu so in general it
won't be but if s is if s is constructed
out of some nice procedure I'm going to
get to it eventually then
you know roughly intuitively I need to I
need you to keep this number in mind the
moments you would sort of you know end
up requiring of the distribution mu
would grow as log of 1 over Delta where
Delta is this you know approximate
convexity yes so so that the approximate
convexity is a notion of sorry what yes
because you can just take 1 1 Rank 1
matrix yes I'm coming to that I'm gonna
give you this trivial bounds
this is the bound that you just
mentioned that any set of vectors just
trivially because you know they are not
more than 2 to the Waffen vectors after
you know taking some fine enough epsilon
net just taking one one of these vectors
would give me 1 Rank 1 matrix so it will
give me that Delta is at least 2 to the
minus some o of n right on the other
hand Delta is clearly at post one
because rank one matrices are not convex
ok these these are trivial bounds you
all you are all with me here right ok so
now I can reveal the the the the
structure theorem that we proved which
is like sort of the key behind this
algorithm which is that the set of rank
one matrices is 2 to the minus Big O of
root n convex
okay in other words for every subset of
you know unit vectors there is a subset
of some to do minus root and measure
inside this set so that the expectation
of rank one matrices on these vectors
the secretary set is going to be close
to rank one okay
you are using a uniform measure eating a
uniform hat like you take this subset of
yes yes yes the measure need not be
uniform but you can always think of it
as uniform by let's say I have in multi
sets of vectors okay good great so now
this is not a corollary that I expect
you to see all the way through but
roughly you know from where from where
we have been like talking about you can
roughly see that this will give you some
you know rounding that will use degree
route end moments of MU so you know
roughly you can see some two to the root
n time algorithm appearing yes if we're
just talking about vectors you sort of
want them to be pointing in the same
direction yeah you get to play with more
cancellation there's
right so in some sense you know maybe
one representative example is like a gap
so imagine like a cap centered at a sec
of fixed vector and now you know you
have like a random vectors in some cap
around it now in some sense if you
average out these vectors the
contributions in any direction which are
like far away from this sort of center
of the cap would sort of you know be
attenuated because they happen with some
tiny probability while the central
vector you know keeps sort of a large
weight so now averaging out we sort of
make you closer and closer to this you
know Rank 1 matrix on this single vector
and this is the kind of effect you're
shooting for here okay good great so I
want to tell you an example and then
perhaps end ok seems like clearly is for
the longer talk that I planned so just
to tell you why this routine comes from
and just to give you so have one
concrete example in mind let's think of
mu which is uniform over you know the
plus minus 1 hypercube scale down to be
just you know unit norm vectors okay so
first clearly you know if I take the
expectation with respect to MU of XX
transpose this is going to be like 1
over N times identity which is as far
away from being rank one as you know
when one can get so in particular you
know for this set is an example that I
cannot be one convex like rank one
matrices cannot be one convex but now I
somehow want to go to produce some large
enough subsets of you know this set
there's a hypercube such that restricted
to it you know the average of rank one
matrices is close to being rank one
right so here is my construction my
construction is basically just take the
distribution mu mu prime which is mu
conditioned on first 10 root and
coordinates fixed to be let us say
positive okay so the hypercube has n
dimensions I've fixed like 10 root and
coordinates so all you all agree that
this is a subset of size some 2 to the
minus 10 root n fraction of the point
from the hypercube right so this this is
the kind of Delta we are shooting for
now I were to convince you that the
expectation of you know that uniform
distribution over this is this condition
distribution sorry expectation with
respect to MU prime of XX transpose is
close to Rank 1 this is what I want to
convince you now
okay it's like a trivial calculation
because the first ten routine
coordinates are fixed the first ten do
ten by ten to ten blocks will be the
constant entry one over n right you know
because of Independence I will have the
cross terms being zero and the remaining
n minus ten routine coordinates would be
basically like identity okay so now I
can know this part was ranked one I can
pull it out this is the vector that
corresponds to the rank one part and now
I somehow want to say that this rank one
term really dominates this matrix in
Frobenius oh okay and this is like a
trivial calculation just that you know
this 101 an identity has four Benyus
norm roughly 1 over square root of n
well this vector was chosen to have norm
some 10 over square root of n or
whatever just because I chose 10 root n
coordinates to fix okay so is this
example clear why I can somehow
condition or ten do ten coordinates and
get something this is some subset which
is approximately convex here great yes
so can I have five minutes
three minutes three minutes ten minutes
is good
hi I am an Indian I learned bargaining
when I was a kid okay so so so okay so
let's let me try to tell you how to
prove this structure theorem okay and
and I I want to spend three minutes
because I want to introduce the third
player in the title the log rank
conjecture it had to appear somewhere so
I'll tell you how you know this recent
breakthrough on the log rank conjecture
relates to proving this theorem okay so
just to remind you what the log line
conjecture is it's some conjecture in
communication complexity which are not
good to say it I'm going to set an
equivalent formulation due to Nissan
Victor sin' which is also by the way the
main line of attack on this conjecture
so if you care about it in some sense
this is probably the right way to start
those conjecture say it's the following
suppose you have a matrix whose entries
are plus minus one valued okay and it's
rank is small n okay and you should
really be thinking of matrices which
have like huge dimensions so exponential
in small n versus exponential in small n
matrices with really low ranks a small n
rank okay then the logline conjecture
says that there is a sub matrix of this
huge matrix which has 2 to the minus
poly noggin fraction of rows and columns
such that this sub matrix is basically
monochromatic in particular Rank 1 is a
conjecture clear great we don't know how
to prove this there are tons of works on
this I'm not going to survey them here
but basically three years ago there was
a breakthrough to Shahadah ovett who
proved like in some sense the first
non-trivial upper bound on the logline
conjecture
he showed that every boolean matrix has
a monochromatic sub matrix with measure
cuckoo the minus root square root of n
so we wanted to the minus polynomial and
we can't prove that but we can to to the
minus square root of n okay and I want
you to keep this picture in mind because
that's what we're going to use in the
next slide a rank small in matrix can be
thought of as basically having rows and
columns indexed by n dimensional vectors
and the entry is given by the you know
inner products of the vectors indexing
rows and columns okay and you know lower
edge theorem says that there is some
rank 1 sub matrix which is M to the
minus root and fracture of the big
matrix great so for for showing you this
sketch of the proof of the structure
theorem that I showed you before
to assume like a wishful version of this
routing theorem where the bullion ID
condition is not required okay while you
are with me let's just assume that the
boolean ID condition is not crucial and
let's assume that this wishful version
of our theorem was true okay great
so here is what I want to prove that the
rank 1 manifold is 2 to the minus Oh
fruit and convex so again like let's say
mu is uniform over some u 1 u 2 u
capital n what I'm going to do is the
following I take the gram matrix of
these vectors okay you want u to u
capital n is going to be some capital N
by capital n matrix I'll apply the root
rank theorem the root rank atom gives me
some sub sub matrix which is defined by
subset of rows and columns
which is equivalent to choosing some
subset of these vectors right so far so
far you with me it gives me a subset of
this vectors which is of sine to the
minus or fruit n times capital n so says
when I restrict the ground matrix to
just this subset of vectors then it is
approximately Rank 1 ok and now all I'm
using is that the gram matrix and The
Associated covariance matrix have the
same spectrum so in particular this also
ailes that expectation restricted to s
of UI UI transpose is close to Rank 1 ok
great
so that's that that's basically the
proof going ahead I showed you sort of a
caricaturist version of with the
structure theorem at some point I
mentioned that we need to care about how
does this matrix expectation with
respect to the subset s of UI UI
transpose look in particular we would
want it to be function of low degree
moments for this we require that you
know this construction of this set has
been nice that nice corresponds to some
polynomial relating business that I'm
not going to get into and you know this
then this question of proving the
wishful routing theorem so it turns out
that we use a sort of a generalization
of the argument due to Tomas for you
know the proof of the lower theorem or
the root rank theorem and you know
that's probably what I'm going to say
about how we prove this but you know
that hopefully that gives you some idea
of how this stuff works
we of course have to make this work for
something that we can compute the moment
of a distribution supported and
solutions something not not what we can
compute so this part you know we we have
to do is part where we go back and check
what constraints we used and we can
relax it to
some set which can be efficiently
computed etc etc not going to get into
that I'm just gonna leave this slide on
and finish thank you in that Delta
convexity question is - the - rudeness
awesome that's a great question yes in
fact the hypercube example I showed you
is can be shown to be tight so yes so
for making further progress on this
better purpose a problem in fact related
problems like - - for normal sponsor
expansion you need to go to some
variants where you are not hit with this
lower bound and there are variants and I
can talk about it offline but yes as
stated the the proof technique etc is
tight
yeah like the formulation that you can't
the beginning right play not just a
prank on matrix and substrates this is
essentially equivalent to solving
arbitrary quadratic equations yeah
that's a great question and and I think
the issue is what is the notion of
approximation I think the issue is what
is your notion of approximation in some
sense we are solving quadratic equations
in this notion of being close to the
subspace defined by the equations right
like in some sense the norm is what
makes this possible you know in if you
have a bunch of equations right right so
I think in some sense we are looking at
okay I think there is a way to think of
like some primal and dual and I think
when you think of this quadratic
equation problem you usually think in
primal like you want to satisfy each of
the equations across some tiny accuracy
I think the projection or the Frobenius
something corresponds to some dual
distance and somehow it happens to be
the right thing for these problems like
two to four norm and precipice eight
things like that but yeah in general if
you think about quadratic equations
which you know up to change of norm is
the same question then of course you
can't expect this algorithm you know we
would we would basically have
exponential hardness I think assuming
ETH
yeah so I mean it Thomas's coop I guess
some shoppers if you have like two steps
like a discrepancy step and
combinatorial instead so I guess you
only need the first part actually
intimacies proof there is no discrepancy
in step me buy the discrepancy thing
falls out as a corollary okay you can
correct me if I'm wrong not exactly sure
what you mean it's like almost
monochromatic yeah that but you need
like that one theorem that if it's all
almost from monochromatic said there was
something big
actually what yeah I see
okay so sorry so in this application we
don't care about the difference between
monochromatic and almost monochromatic
you're right in the bully oddity case
it's sort of is first of all it's not
even a meaningful question in when the
major says are not boolean and in some
sense like we are all working in this
approximation land so we are okay with
approximately rank one matrices so yes
so in some sense the combinatorial
cleanup step of like from almost
monochromatic going to monochromatic
that sort of doesn't appear in this
argument
okay let's thank Britt
[Applause]